-- will try it again at the end
of this lecture and you show you
that stuff hopefully next time.
For today we are going to start
with nonlinear analysis.
Before we do that I wanted to
do a little bit of review.
I wanted to give you the past
three weeks in perspective and
show you how all of these things
fit into the grand scheme of
things.
We began by building a great
little playground,
and within that playground we
said that by enforcing upon
ourselves the lumped matter
discipline we created the lumped
circuit abstraction.
So within that playfield we
assumed that we had dq by dt and
d phi by dt to be 0 so that gave
us as the lumped circuit
abstraction.
And within that lumped circuit
abstraction, within this
playground we looked at several
methods of analyzing circuits,
including the KVL,
KCL method.
We also learned the method
involving composing resistors,
the voltage dividers and so on
and solving circuits
intuitively.
And we also looked at the node
method, which is kind of the
workhorse of the circuits
industry.
So when in doubt apply the node
method and it will get you where
you want to go.
Now, we also said that this is
good, here is our playground.
We said hey,
if we focus on those circuits
that are linear we come to the
left part of our playground.
And we said that for linear
circuits in this part of the
playground we can further use a
couple of techniques,
a few techniques,
superposition,
Thevenin, Norton and so on.
So these techniques allow you
to very quickly analyze
complicated circuits,
especially when you're looking
to find a single current,
or voltage or some parameter of
interest.
Whenever you see,
if you see a circuit containing
multiple voltage sources or two
or more voltage sources or
current sources,
as a first step think
superposition.
And so these are very powerful
techniques that let you analyze
very complicated circuits very
effectively.
After we did this we said,
oh, let me draw another
playground here.
This is another piece of our
playground.
And if these are linear circuit
then this half of the playground
is nonlinear circuits.
And we said that if you further
focus on discretized values,
if you discretized values and
focused only on circuits that
dealt with binary signals,
highs and lows,
then we came into this small
regime of the playground.
And notice that digital
circuits are,
by their very nature,
nonlinear.
Remember the circuit,
A, B, this was one of our NOR
gate circuits?
And if you look at transfer
functions, that is if I plot,
let's say for example,
for some combination of input
values.
Let's say I plot v in verses v
out.
Let's say, for example,
I turned this guy off by
setting B to 0 and then I simply
apply a low to high transition
at v in, then what I would see
at the output is a transfer
function of the following sort
where as v in changes the output
switches at some point and then
stays at a low value.
So when v in is low v out is
high and v in and high v out is
low.
So that's kind of the v out
versus v in when B is set at 0.
So notice that this is a
nonlinear curve.
This is not a straight line.
It's a nonlinear curve.
And so therefore in the digital
domain we see highly nonlinear
functions that look like this
and so on.
However, take a look at this
circuit.
Suppose I focus on the circuit
for a given set of switch
settings.
Let's say, for example,
I focus on the circuit when A
and B are both 1s.
For a given set of switch
settings, notice that I'm going
to be either in this region or
in this region.
Notice that this region is a
straight line.
So if I focus on let's say both
A and B at once then I get
something like this.
And in this situation,
for a given set of switch
settings, notice that my digital
circuit now can be analyzed
using linear techniques.
So therefore my digital gets
moved into the linear domain for
a given set of switch settings.
So if I fix my switch settings
and look at the circuit then
each circuit,
for a given set of switch
settings, is comprised of
voltage sources and some
resistors and it's a linear
circuit.
Again, I can go back and apply
all my linear techniques to
virtually all the digital
circuits that you will be
dealing with in 6.002.
Again, remember if I fix my
switch settings,
if I fix the inputs then the
output can be determined using
linear techniques.
Because the digital circuits
we're showing you in 6.002
simply comprise linear elements
like voltage sources and
resistors and so on.
You'll see some more later.
But you can apply your linear
techniques and analyze them.
The cool thing here is that
with just two weeks of stuff
that you've learned in 6.002,
you are well on our way to
being able to analyze certain
classes of digital circuits for
a given set of switch settings
and many, many,
many linear circuits.
What we will do today is focus
on nonlinear circuits.
So we look at this space.
Notice again that up until now
we've dealt with these three
methods, which apply to all
circuits within this playground,
the lumped circuit playground.
And the subset of that is the
linear domain.
And we can analyze linear
circuits in this way.
And digital circuits,
for a given set of switch
settings, also fall within this
category.
So notice that you can go ahead
and analyze the digital circuits
using superposition or other
techniques like that.
The next big step for us is to
begin our analysis of nonlinear
circuits today.
The important thing to remember
is that nonlinear circuits are
also within this big playground
in which we are going under the
lumped matter discipline.
So nonlinear circuits are also
lumped circuits.
And therefore because we are in
that playground we can use any
one of our techniques,
KVL, KCL or the node method to
analyze nonlinear circuits.
So if you see a nonlinear
circuit, don't get daunted.
Just remember this is meant to
be simple stuff.
So let me simply write down the
node equation and analyze it.
There is really nothing new in
today's lecture.
I'm just going to show you a
nonlinear circuit and analyzing
using techniques that you
already know.
Today nonlinear circuits.
And we look at several methods
of analyzing nonlinear circuits.
We look at the "Analytic
Method".
We look at a "Graphical
You will look at a "Piecewise
Linear Method" in the book.
I won't be covering this in
lecture.
You can read Section 4.4 for
the piecewise linear method.
In this method you take your
curves and you approximate them
with a bunch of straight line
segments, kind of like the v
out, v in curve I've shown you
there, and analyze the circuit
using linear techniques within
any given straight line segment.
We will also do incremental
analysis.
This is also called small
signal analysis.
So I will cover these two
today, I will introduce this one
today, and wrap that up during
the next lecture.
Let's start with a simple
example.
So I have some voltage,
V, some voltage source V.
And I have some resistor,
R.
And I have a fictitious device
here that I labeled D.
Let's call this fictitious
device the "Expo Dweeb".
I purposely chose a funky name
because this is a fictitious
device.
Let's call it the Expo Dweeb.
And let me write down the
associated variables for this
device as follows.
iD is the current flowing into
this terminal and vD is the
voltage across this device.
So this is a nonlinear device.
And this device is
characterized by the following
equation.
Much like resistors were
characterized by an iV relation,
V is equal to iR,
or i is equal to V/R.
This device is also
characterized by the following
element relationship.
It's a e raised to bvD.
So there is an exponentiation
here.
Again, this is a fictitious
device.
And I'll show some funky things
that it does in a second.
It's a very simple relation.
It's an exponential relation
where the current relates to the
exponentiated value of the
voltage vD across the element.
So I can plot iD versus vD for
this element as follows.
Notice that when vD is 0 iD is
a, so I have a here,
and it looks like this.
It's a funny device,
a fictitious device.
So when vD is 0,
I have some current flowing the
device, and as vD increases I
get an exponential increase in
the current through that device.
This device is funny in the
sense that it is not a passive
device in that notice that when
vD and iD are positive the
product is positive,
which is fine,
which says that it is consuming
power.
On the other hand,
on the left-hand side notice
that the vI relation is
negative, which means that when
I put a negative voltage on it,
it can still sustain a positive
current.
This must imply that the device
is producing power.
But for the purpose of a
nonlinear analysis we don't have
to worry about that.
Let's just do it mathematically
and find out what it looks like.
So back to this again.
I have a voltage source,
a resistor and my Expo Dweeb
connected in that manner.
Now, again, reflect on this
pattern.
A voltage source or a current
source, a resistor and some
device.
This is a very standard pattern
you will see again and again and
again.
In particular,
if you look at this device,
it's a nonlinear device here.
And facing the nonlinear device
is a voltage source in series
with a resistor.
And the reason I say that this
is an incredibly important
pairing is the following.
Notice that if on the left-hand
side I had any linear circuit
and I had a single nonlinear
element in that circuit.
Notice that by a Thevenin
reduction that you've learned
you can take this entire mess.
If all you care about is the
behavior of the nonlinear
device, for the purpose of
analyzing this nonlinear device,
you can take this entire linear
circuit, no matter how
complicated it is,
voltage sources,
current sources,
resistors and a bunch of other
funky stuff, you can boil all of
that down to a Thevenin
equivalent, a voltage and a
resistor in series.
So we can trick you.
We can give you a complicated
circuit and say ah-ha,
tell me what the current is
through this device if I apply
some voltage,
3 volts there.
What you can do is you can say
ah-ha, I don't care what happens
here so I'm just going to
replace the whole thing with a
Thevenin equivalent.
And you've done your homework
now and you can calculate
Thevenin equivalents for
circuits.
And simply replace this and
then go ahead and solve the
circuit.
Again, remember we are
engineers.
We are looking for answers.
We are looking to build
interesting systems.
And, in general,
we like to take the simplest
path possible to the solution.
So simplify your lives and
create a simple Thevenin coupled
to a nonlinear device and then
you will be rolling.
When we talk about a variety of
other circuits,
nonlinear circuits,
time-varying circuits and so on
in the rest of this course,
we will look at this pattern
again and again and again and
again until we are blue in the
face.
And, just remember,
the reason we keep looking at
this pattern is that whenever
you have some big linear mess
connected to some interesting
device what you can do is if all
you care about is analyzing the
behavior of that device,
you can take this linear mess
and simply figure out the
Thevenin equivalent,
or the Norton equivalent if you
like and replace this whole
thing with its equivalent and
then go ahead and analyze it.
So boil an arbitrarily circuit
down to a very simple pattern of
this sort.
What this means is because of
this brilliant Thevenin
simplification,
going forward through the rest
of this course we will mostly
deal with very simple circuits
like this, voltage source,
resistor and the device.
That's it.
Very, very, very rarely will
you see multiple sources and
lots of resistors in a circuit.
It's usually going to be simple
stuff.
And remember how we got here,
by making a Thevenin
simplification of a linear mess.
All right.
If in homeworks or quizzes or
in real life,
or in many examples of real
life, if you find that you have
to deal with a lot of grunge and
a lot of mess,
step back and think a little
bit.
Try to use intuition and see if
you can simplify things using
some clever trick or method.
Method 1 of analysis.
Let's go ahead and analyze this
pattern here,
this template circuit,
if you will,
a voltage source a resistor and
a nonlinear device.
This is the analytical method.
And remember the node method
applies, so let me go ahead and
apply the node method.
To apply the node method,
what do I do?
I first have to select a ground
node.
Let me insulate this as my
ground node.
Let me label all the nodes with
their voltages.
So this node has voltage V and
this node has label the capital
D.
So let me go ahead and analyze
this using the node method.
So the node method says for
each of the nodes in the circuit
whose voltage is not known go
ahead and write down KCL
implicitly applying the element
relationships to replace the
current values with the voltage
values.
Let's start with the current
going in that direction.
Current going from the vD node
through resistor R,
which looks as follows,
vD - V divided by R.
That's a current going that
way.
And the current going down is
iD.
In general, when I apply the
node method, I don't write iD
here but I go ahead and write
the element relation ae to the
bvD here.
Then I get an equation in vD
and I just solve the mode
voltage.
However, just to make a couple
of extra points later,
let me go ahead and do that in
two steps, write down this and
then go ahead and write down iD
separately as ae to the bvD.
Again, remember,
don't get confused here.
In a node method,
I don't write down a second
step.
I directly write down ae to bvD
in place of iD.
I get one equation in vD,
I go solve it.
Just for fun today,
I'm taking two steps here,
writing iD and explicitly
putting down iD as ae to the
bvD.
Now, that's it.
I mean this is all there is to
it.
You guys can now go ahead and
analyze nonlinear circuits.
You get a bunch of equations,
a bunch of unknowns,
go solve.
I have two equations here.
vD and iD are my unknowns and I
can just go ahead and solve for
them.
Now, in general with nonlinear
circuits, often times it's hard
to get a closed form solution so
you may have to use a bunch of
methods.
You can try a closed form
solution or you can try
numerical solutions or you can
do trial and error.
In this case,
I'll just go ahead and tell
you.
Suppose I choose V as 1 volt,
R is 1 ohm and b is 1 over volt
and a is ยบ amps for those
values, approximately vD is
roughly 0.5 volts and iD is
roughly 0.4 volts.
You can do this by using trial
and error or other methods.
In 6.002 we don't dwell on
working too hard to solve
equations of this sort.
If you cannot substitute this
in here and solve it directly,
we don't ask you to go and
learn numerical method and the
techniques and so on to solve
it.
But just remember that you can
use trial and error or you can
use back substitution and other
techniques that you will learn
in future numerical methods
classes and apply it here.
But suffice it to say that,
for here we can stick with
trial and error if you like.
And for these values,
vD and iD are 0.5 and
approximately 0.4.
You're done.
It's really that simple.
Yes.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Good catch.
I know there is one person
that's not sleeping here.
Good.
So, as I said,
there's not a whole lot to it.
Whether it's a nonlinear
circuit or a linear circuit and
as long as I am inside this
playground here where the lumped
circuit abstraction holds,
I can apply my node equations
and then go ahead and solve it.
Let me show you a few more
methods so we can articulate
your repertoire of tools for
nonlinear circuits.
And I'd like to show you a
graphical technique.
I personally rarely use a
graphical technique to solve
circuits.
And why am I sharing this with
you?
It turns out that often times
by looking at things graphically
you can get some better insights
into circuit behavior.
You can also show cool demos
when you show graphs of
responses kind of playing with
each other and so on.
So this is fun for getting
intuition and things like that.
Graphically all I'm really
going to do is solve those two
equations graphically.
So I'm going to plot equation
one.
Let me rewrite equation one as
follows.
iD is --
I'm just rewriting equation one
as follows.
V/R - vD/R.
And I can also draw the second
guy --
OK, I can do this as well.
I can do an iD versus vD plot.
And in this particular
situation, you've seen this
already, that's my iD versus vD
curve right there.
And I can do the same for this
one here.
So this equation establishes
the following straight line
relationship.
It says that when vD is 0,
iD is V/R.
So that's here.
And similarly when iD is 0 then
vD is equal to V so I get
something here.
So that's my straight line
relationship corresponding to
this equation here.
So what I can do is I can
simply solve these by
superimposing the two curves on
the same vD, iD template here
and finding the intersection of
the curves.
So I can take this curve
corresponding to two and I can
take this curve corresponding to
one, and this is V/R and this is
V, 0, and I can find the
intersection point.
This curve here,
for reasons that will be
obvious about three weeks from
now, is called the load line.
It's called the load line.
You will understand why that is
so in a later lecture.
So I've given you a template on
Page 6 to boil these two down
into one equation.
So there, again,
you can substitute the values
for V is 1 volt and R is 1 and
so on and so forth and get the
same kind of result as you did
previously.
So there is really nothing new
here.
All I've done in the second
method is combined the two
equations graphically and found
the solution by looking at where
the two curves intersect.
At the start of the lecture I
also told you that you may want
to go and check out the
piecewise linear technique --
-- in Section 4.4 of the course
notes.
All right.
For today let me do a third
method called "Incremental
Analysis".
This technique is also called
the small signal method.
I'm going to show you,
before I go into the method,
in today's lecture what I'll do
is I'll give you a motivating
example for why we need the
small signal approach.
I'll give you a motivating
example and show you a little
demo.
And then I will close with
showing you a problem with
applying a standard approach,
and I'll ask you to see if you
can figure out a way to handle
it in time for next lecture.
So let me give you the
motivation here.
So here is what I want to do.
Many of you have seen one of
those electric eye garage door
openers, right?
You have a receiver at one end
and you have some kind of a
light beam at the other,
and when you walk through it
stops, or rather it cuts the
circuit and stops the door from
closing.
And when no one is going
through it maintains a
connection and lets the door
close.
So what we did is we went to
Home Depot, or one of those
stores, and bought a very
standard device that essentially
produces some response when
light impinges on it.
And my goal will be to see if I
can send music over the light
beam using a simple garage door
opener device.
So here is the little circuit
that I will do.
We actually went there and
built this.
I will also show you a demo.
Here is my time-varying
voltage, vI(t),
and this is some music signal.
And get some music signal.
And I want to connect this to
this device, which is a device
found in garage door openers.
I am going to call it a LED.
If you like,
you can view it as,
this is very similar to our
Expo Dweeb.
This is called a "Light
Emitting Expo Dweeb".
That's why it is LED.
So what the LED does is,
as I apply this voltage across
it, that same voltage appears
across the Light Emitting Expo
Dweeb.
And there is some current that
flows through the device.
And for our analysis we will
assume that this device
virtually has an identical iD
characteristic to the Expo Dweeb
just that it emits light.
So when I pass a current
through it, it emits light.
And the light intensity is
proportional to the current that
flows through.
So it emits light and light
intensity, LD,
is proportional to iD.
Here is my little light
emitting device,
which when current flows
through it, itproduces light
because its intensity is
proportional to the current.
And what I will do is I will
stick in the receiver here.
Think of it as a photo resistor
or some other device where I am
going to connect that in a
circuit.
I am not going to spend too
much time on this side.
I'm going to focus on the
left-hand side here.
And let's say I have some kind
of amplifier and speakers and so
on and so forth.
Suffice it to say that when the
light falls on this device PR
that iR that goes through here
is proportional to the received
light intensity.
So if the current is
proportional to the received
light intensity then I amplify
that signal in my amplifier and
I get the music playing out
here.
And notice that the following
chain of dependences apply.
So I have an input music signal
VI.
That gets converted to some iD.
These are all time-varying
signals, so VI is a time-varying
signal and so is iD.
And iD gets converted to light
of some intensity LD.
This in turn gets attenuated
somewhat and is received at the
photo resistor.
And I get some intensity LR
impinging on that device there.
And that in turn produces a
current iR and then iR is
amplified and goes through a
speaker and so on and produces
sound.
Notice that using this chain
I've taken a music signal here
and I am playing it here.
And just imagine that this is
your garage door opener device
here where the light emitted is
being articulated by the voltage
signal VI.
And received here.
So notice that if I cut this,
if I stick something in here
and block it then I get no
response here,
but if I take my hand away then
I do get some response.
But this is fine.
This should work.
You could try this at home if
you'd like.
If you have a garage door
opener, just stick a little
circuit like this and it should
simply work.
We have a problem,
though.
The problem is that,
as I said, I'm using the Expo
Dweeb here, the light emitting
Expo Dweeb, and its
characteristics are as follows.
iD is exponentially related to
the voltage vD,
so this is nonlinear.
And that's a real problem.
Because this is nonlinear,
I am going to get a distorted
output.
Let me show you a little wave
form, a little graph to show you
how the distortion happens and
then show you a little demo
showing you the distortion.
Let me graphically show you the
kind of distortion that is
happening here,
and I will do it by drawing the
following graph.
So this is the vD,
iD curve for our device.
And what I'm going to plot for
you is if I have a time-varying
vD voltage, I just want to see
what the time-varying iD current
looks like.
And a trick to plot that is to
take your input voltage like so.
And let's say I apply a
sinusoid.
So I am just taking a
time-varying sinusoidal voltage
and rotating the plot 90 degrees
like so, so I can see where
these points correspond to on
that curve.
So what this says is that at
some point here,
for example,
where vI, at this point and
time, vI is here.
Notice vI and vD are the same
thing because vI is applied
across vD.
vI directly applies across the
device, and so vI equals vD at
all time.
So this voltage here
corresponds to this voltage,
it corresponds to this current
and then I can find out what the
current is for that voltage.
By using the same artifice I
can plot the output current iD
like so.
So for this value I get some
current here.
And so at time T0 I start here.
And notice that as this signal
moves up here,
I can find out the
corresponding values of iD by
looking at where a straight line
intersects here and plotting the
values here.
I have a nice little graphical
animation to show you this.
Hopefully, the laptop will work
tomorrow and we can check that.
I am doing nothing new here.
Just showing you a trick to be
able to plot vI versus v out
relationships,
or vI or versus other
relationships based on some kind
of a transfer function.
So what you end up getting is
something that looks like this.
Why is that?
Notice that this curve here
corresponds to the signal.
As this signal moves from here
to here, this point moves from
here to here and that
corresponds to this iD.
When this moves from here to
here that corresponds to a point
moving from this part of the
curve to here,
and that looks like so.
And then for the whole negative
incursion, notice that the whole
negative incursion moves here,
so for that entire negative
incursion I get an output that
looks like this.
Notice that this device has
completely cut off and hammered
negative going signals.
What it's done is that rather
than giving me a nice little
negative spike incursion here,
or excursion here,
what this is doing is that it
is taking this excursion and
simply slamming it down to this
value here.
And then again,
when I go back up,
I get this peak here.
So notice that what was a nice
little sinusoid out there gets
hammered and squished into this
funny curve here.
What this device is doing is
for positive values it tends to
produce exponentially greater
current so I get boom,
high-rising peaks corresponding
to these two,
and for negative going voltages
it simply compresses them to a
low positive value here.
And that's what I see here
corresponding to negative
excursion.
So notice that what this will
do, if I view sound,
if I input sound here,
and sound has negative going
excursions it will simply
scrunch them.
But more or less let the
positive things through.
And that is going to give rise
to a bunch of distortion in my
signal.
So I would like to show you a
little demo.
Actually, we've gone ahead and
built a little device like this.
We have an honest to goodness
little device costing,
I don't know,
50 cents or $1 or something,
which is a little voltage,
it's a device that emits light
proportional to the current
flowing through it.
I have a receiver.
And I am going to play some
music, and you will listen to
the output here.
And hopefully you should see a
bunch of distortion because of
that effect that I showed you.
And what I will do is,
before we do that,
you will see two curves up
there.
The yellow, I believe is the
vI, is the input,
and the green,
I believe, is a signal
proportionate to --
The other way around.
Oh, I see.
So green is the input.
So green, the lower one is the
input and the upper one is the
distorted output.
So we are going to play some
sound through it,
music through it and you can
listen, through a little CD
player.
So a couple of things.
The good news is that it works.
However, I doubt that music
artists will come to my studio
to record if this is the quality
of what I produce.
Do notice that there are hardly
any negative going excursions in
that curve up there,
right?
All the negative ones have been
like scrunched up down into a
flat line there,
and that's the reason I get
this distortion.
And just to prove to you that I
am indeed using a garage door
opener device and not faking it
here, I am going to just shut
the signal off by stopping the
light using a piece of paper
here.
So notice that this device here
is the little device that has a
light beam going through the
center, and I am going to take
this piece of paper,
can you turn it up?
So let's have some fun with
this.
If I were to put this piece of
paper halfway down,
I should get half the
intensity, right.
So my sound should diminish in
volume a little bit.
Maybe that will work.
Let's see if it works.
Nothing to do with 002 but it's
just fun.
Louder.
You can make it loud.
Too much coffee.
My hand is shaking.
I guess you did see the
lowering of volume,
right?
OK.
Just way too much coffee,
and so my hand was shaking too
fast imposing its own sine wave
on top of the signal.
What did I show you?
This was garbage,
right?
We had a nice little signal
input, and the output was
completely distorted because I
was playing sound over this and
this is what happened.
Switch to Page 9.
Now, this is what I would have
liked to have happened.
On Page 9 what I would have
liked to see happen is this.
Suppose I had a light emitting
device that looked linear,
a straight line where the
current was linearly related to
vD.
Then what I would see,
if I had a sinusoid here then I
would get a sinusoid here.
No distortion there,
right?
If only things were like I
wanted them, if I had a linear
device, but I don't have a
linear device.
I have an Expo Dweeb.
Now you know why I call it a
dweeb.
Well, I'd like a linear device
and it's exponential.
But this is what I would like.
And if I had this I wouldn't
show it to you today.
If I had this my music would go
through without any distortion
and I wouldn't have to run
cables through my attic.
I could just use my garage door
opener to play signals from my
bedroom and living room and so
on, right?
So the key thing here is how do
I get this?
And what I would like you to do
is think about it yourselves.
What I am given is something
like this.
This about it yourselves,
you know, what would you do?
See if you can come to me
before lecture tomorrow or
Thursday and tell me the answer,
OK?